[Música]
vocês já pararam para pensar como é o
vestuário das pessoas com deficiência
se tem alguma diferença ou se deveria
ter o meu papel como estilista de moda
inclusiva é criar um vestuário que
abraço a todos
pessoas com e sem deficiência
hoje eu vou contar pra vocês porque eu
trabalho com isso e porque esse assunto
mexeu tanto comigo
tudo começou em 2009 quando ainda eu
estava em busca de um tema pro meu
trabalho de conclusão de curso e um dia
passou por mim um guri numa cadeira de
rodas e foi ali naquele momento pela
primeira vez na vida que eu comecei a
pensar sobre o assunto
como será que ele se veste será que tem
alguma dificuldade para colocar a roupa
será que precisa da ajuda de alguém
ou será que tem interesse por moda e aí
essas coisas ficaram na minha cabeça e
eu resolvi fazer o meu trabalho sobre
isso aí eu fiz um estudo para entender
as implicações e as limitações do
vestuário para mulheres cadeirantes
daí eu conversei com diversas mulheres
inclusive com para atletas que estavam
em porto alegre naquela ocasião e elas
me contaram que sim que todas elas
tinham interesse por moda
porém quase todas elas tinham
dificuldade de encontrar um vestuário
que atendessem às suas necessidades
então muitas vezes elas compravam uma
roupa 12 números maiores
levavam na costureira para fazer alguns
ajustes e aquilo fazia com que perdesse
o caimento da peça hora que elas perdiam
muito tempo e pediu dinheiro
e muitas vezes elas deixavam de usar
algo que elas realmente gostariam porque
ela sabia o que aquilo não ficaria bem
no corpo delas
após esse trabalho nessas conversas
a conclusão que eu cheguei é que esse
vestuário era realmente necessário e o
meu propósito como estilista era esse
fazer roupas pra todo mundo
a primeira roupa adaptada que eu fiz foi
para juliana foi um desfile com outras
mulheres sem deficiência e eu fiz pra
ela uma calça com cosme bem alto
elástico na cintura para dar maior
conforto
fiz um zíper discreto para poder fazer a
troca da sonda que é muito usada por
quem usa cadeira de rodas
eu fiz uma camisa que ao invés de botões
eu coloquei velcro para facilitar o
vestido despida peça e nas costas não
tinha nenhuma costura e nenhum recorde
para não formar esses caras que são
feridas causadas pelo atrito da pele com
alguma superfície e obviamente não
coloquei bolso nas costas porque não
fazia sentido
este outro desfile eu convidei mulheres
com vários tipos de deficiência para
desfilar com outra sem deficiência e eu
fiz pra car lena uma blusa que tinha
abertura nos ombros
com o fechamento de botão de pressão pra
facilitar na hora de passar a cabeça
aliás pra pessoas são tetraplégicas o
ideal é pensar num vestuário que
facilite quem vai vestir a pessoa e para
paraplégicos que de autonomia para a
pessoa poder se vestir sozinha neste
último desfile que eu fiz eu convidei
homens mulheres com e sem deficiência
e pra pat eu fiz uma saia bem ergonômica
eu já fiz ela na posição sentada dar
maior conforto pra gisele que é
deficiente visual eu fiz um vestido que
ela podia usar de muitas maneiras de
cima para baixo
acho de baixo para cima reversível e eu
escrevi o nome dela em braile para poder
identificar que aquela peça seria que
ela usaria no dia do desfile
aliás o ideal seria sempre pensarmos em
fazer tags etiquetas em braille as
pessoas poderem ter acesso a algumas
informações básicas como tamanho e cor
da peça aí de kelly dinamismo e para as
mulheres com nanismo ou baixa estatura
o ideal é tão sábios em peças um estilo
adulto mas com adaptações para que elas
não precisem mais encontrar roupa ideal
na seção infantil das lojas
imagina roupas com motivos de princesa e
cor de rosa e parece brincadeira mas é a
realidade de muita gente
o que mais me emociona desse meu
trabalho é que eu lido com a autoestima
dessas pessoas
elas sentem bonitas e valorizadas
isso é muito gratificante no brasil
existe mais de 45 milhões de pessoas com
alguma deficiência
isso significa mais de 23% da população
segundo os dados do ibge é de 2010
mas a boa notícia é que as empresas já
estão pensando estão produzindo produtos
mais modernos como cadeiras de rodas
coloridas próteses estampadas materiais
mais leves e mais tecnológicos
vocês sabiam que foi no brasil que
tivemos o primeiro concurso de moda
inclusiva do mundo que já está na décima
edição eu participei da terceira e eu
fiz um vestido de festa para juliana e
eu tirei segundo lugar eu a silvana a
brinca e várias outras pessoas e várias
outros estilistas
pequenas marcas já estão adaptando peças
nas suas coleções
mas foi lá fora que as grandes empresas
e marcas famosas e conceituadas se deram
conta da real necessidade desse
vestuário e já estão lançando coleções
exclusivas como americana tommy e já
está na sua segunda coleção inclusiva
devido ao tamanho do sucesso que foi a
primeira ea target também americana
recentemente lançou uma coleção
inclusiva
todos nós devemos pensar nisso
devemos ter empatia olhar para o outro
o mundo está mudando as pessoas estão
mais conscientes e a moda também está
mudando junto
hoje eu estou aqui falando sobre moda
inclusiva porque eu preciso chamar a
atenção sobre esse tema mas que no
futuro eu não preciso usar mais esse
termo porque seremos todos iguais com
nossas diferenças
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]